hallo leute in dieser episode möchten
wir mit euch kochen wir sind keine
kochsendung also erwartet bitte keine
neuen rezepte von uns aber wir möchten
euch das vokabular rund ums kochen näher
bringen los geht's
[Musik]
wir kochen heute ein spaghetti richard e
kennt ihr alle die lange form von nudeln
und wir werden spaghetti kochen mit
einer zu machen basilikum sauce mit
frischen tomaten zucchini und vegan
welchen da wir vegetarisch kochen
dazu brauchen wir natürlich auch gewürze
basilikum haben wir frisch da haben wir
leider nicht frisch das heißt benutzten
knoblauch granulat natürlich auch salz
pfeffer wir werden wahrscheinlich auch
etwas paprika nutzen und vielleicht noch
ein paar andere gewürze zum kochen
benötigen wir einen großen kochtopf um
die spaghetti zu kochen dann um das
wasser später abschließen wie es sie
dann werden wir das gemüse in einem wok
anbraten
man kann natürlich auch eine fahne
benutzen aber ich nutze immer gerne
einen bock dann haben wir eine nudel
dafür für die spaghetti einen kochlöffel
für die soße einen vollen wende um die
zucchini umzudrehen und die vegan
welchen und natürlich das kommt als
erstes zum vorschein ein gutes
schneidemesser und die zeugnisse
schneiden auf diesen schneidebrett so
jetzt fangen wir an erst einmal stellen
wir den herd angehört vertan und werden
etwas öl in den topf gießen
nun werden wir als erstes die zucchini
schneiden wir haben natürlich schon die
zucchini und die tomaten alles gewaschen
und ganz wichtig vorher natürlich die
hände gründlich waschen gerade in diesen
zeiten
jetzt kommen die zucchini in die fahne
auch sie war schon sehr heiß
[Musik]
jetzt beraten wir die zucchini in öl an
die zucchini zwischendurch natürlich
immer schön wenden
zucchini jetzt würzen mit salz knoblauch
und paprika
die zucchini braten sie in öl mit den
gewürzen an bis sie etwas braun werden
jetzt werden wir die tomaten schneiden
die dann ebenfalls in die fahne kommen
[Musik]
die halbieren wir einfach nur einmal
damit ein bisschen von der von dem
frischen tomatensaft
[Musik]
jetzt wo die zucchini und tomaten gut
angebrochen sind werden wir die veganen
welchen hinzufügen und ebenfalls
anbrachen
jetzt wo wir alles gut angebraten haben
werden wir die tomaten besinnen können
rosen zu finden und das ganze jetzt
etwas länger ziehen lassen während wir
die antiken
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt etwas wasser in wasser
gekocht und werden daher auch schon
schluss
[Musik]
dann fügen wir dem wasser etwas öl hinzu
damit die spaghetti nicht zusammenkleben
und ebenfalls etwas salz von basilikum
schlucken wir einige frische blätter ab
die wir dann später für die spaghetti
nutzen können
das wasser kocht jetzt können wir die
spaghetti hinzufügen
[Musik]
die nudeln sind jetzt fertig diesen wird
achter abend vor wichtig nicht favorit
sind wir auch gleich mit dem kochen
schon fertig wir sind fertig jetzt
müssen wir die spaghetti nur noch
anrichten auf eine nudel keller ein
bisschen frisches basilikum ist immer
perfekt
[Musik]
das war unsere kleine koch episode
falls sie jetzt noch mehr deutsch lernen
wollt dann probiert doch mal unsere apps
ilek aus dort könnt ihr in einem
vokabeltrainer systematisch die
wichtigsten deutschen vokabeln lernen
von a1 bis b2 viel spaß und bis bald
[Musik]